je pense qu'ils ont fait lever le niveau
d'exploitation de l'aca au plus haut
niveau un
alors pour me donner un peu d espace je
vais parce que j'ai beaucoup de temps
j'ai douze minutes
il paraît que c'est super long je vais
regarder de personnes marque qui est mon
ancien patron il ya 25 ans qui est
devenu mon mentor et qui m'a inspiré ce
que je vais vous raconter aujourd'hui il
ya 25 ans et que j'ai commencé petit à
petit grâce à lui et puis deuxième
personne claire qui m'a aidé en fin de
compte à maîtriser le chaos d'ma mon
cerveau et qui depuis deux mois me
fouette au sens pour réussir à me faire
entrer dans ses douze minutes dont je
grille déjà 20 secondes je peux aussi
imaginer le luxe que je prends parce
qu'elle a été très très forte
donc je suis designer donc je décide des
shows des objets donc des logos des
objets des espaces pour des pour des
marques et au delà de ça j'enseigne ans
parce qu'enfin quand mes étudiants
prennent plein de choses donc c'est
davantage aller enseigner c'est qu'on
apprend des choses et en l'occurrence la
première chose que j'apprends c'est la
sincérité il a fait direct parfois naïf
dans les questions qu'il pose j'enseigne
la gueule le développement et la
construction de marque ou la création de
marques et tous mes cours commencent
chaque semaine chaque année par la même
question est ce qu'on n'est pas en train
de développer des systèmes cynique en
prendre un capitalisme sauvage pour
créer des besoins là où les gens n'ont
pas déjà redit compterait pas besoin
dans le meilleur des cas on est
satisfait et puis on peut recréer des
désirs mais enfin dans ce qui est
important ce n'est pas de savoir si les
marques sont éthiques ou huissiers sont
cyniques passera un jugement de valeur
et en jugeant on se ferme beaucoup de
portes et que tout se dire ce qui anime
ses marques et au delà de ce qu'on peut
juger de ce qu'elles font voir des
'raisons personnelles' fond et j'ai
essayé d engager à découvrir que les
marques et c'est un peu la conclusion
donc tout le reste n'a aucun intérêt
je voulais pas attendre seulement c'est
qu'il marque en fin de compte je redis
ici de voir si les marques ont pas un
inconscient et que cet inconscient quand
les marques qui transforment leurs
conséquences pour notre propre
conscience
les engage pas elle même à se créer une
sorte de conscience une conscience
collective donc là j'ai tout dit
maintenant je vous expliquais enregistré
parce que c'était un peu laborieux
en fait ça a commencé en ouvrant 97 j'ai
une mémoire des dates
j'ai fait un cauchemar absolument atroce
et je me suis réveillé un soir mais
vraiment avec un sentiment d'angoissé
qui est innommable apple venait de
disparaître
j'ai fait le cauchemar qu'a peu
n'existait plus
pour remettre dans le contexte en 97
apple à 2% de part de marché taclé mec
est celle des atolls déjà ils sont
motivés
apple des compatibles aucune
d'imprimantes aucun projecteur vidéo
rien il n'y a pas de typographie
développer c'est un monde clos une sorte
de secte un peu solitaire mais très fier
d'appartenir à ce qu'elle apporte à elle
même et donc en fin de compte dans ce
silence notre réflexion johnny b
pourquoi je suis tellement angoissé à
l'idée qu'apple disparaître toute façon
quoi qu'il arrive ce qui peut arriver de
mieux c'est vraiment histoire qu'un
ordinateur qui marchent en tulle a du
mal à marcher et enfin dans la
perspective de greffer une sorte de
prothèses mécaniques un pc ne me pèse
allant plus là il est 3h du matin calme
quand je pense à ça je vous dis parce
que j'étais pas tout à fait et je me
rends compte en fin de compte en péril
en que que ce qui le rattache à l'idée
de cette angoisse de la dispersion d'un
peu ce n'est pas tellement ce que apple
fait mais c'est ce pour quoi le fait en
fin de compte c'est ce qu'elle
représente ans et je me dis en france
que ce qui va m'angoisser c'est que la
seule entreprise peut-être qu'ils
partagent avec vous une certaine vision
du monde va disparaître cette vision que
l'humain a plus de valeur que la machine
or le débat et eternal date du 10 ème
siècle mais eux ils l'ont emporté alors
à son paroxysme l'idée qu'enfin grande
intelligence est plus importante que la
performance
moi ça m'arrange parce que le moment ça
me fatigue les grands groupes on est
obligé de ta forme en twittant est donc
enfin bon je me dis que cette
disparition n'a pas beaucoup plus
important sans que la sainte disparition
ordinateurs sont toutes parfois bosetti
qu'intéressant agronomique est ça qui m
angoisse
et je me rends compte que ce qui me
rattache à apple c'est pas tellement ce
que je comprends qu'il soit en quoi je
crois il a fait que je partage cette
relance avec elle avec cette marque
alors pour essayer d'avancer mon maître
m'engage à des lectures peu plus
intellectuel que ce que j'avais à
l'époque et il me donne des livres de
lys 3 me cru et le cuit enfin des choses
qui sont pas du tout rigolo temps je
vous conseille penske et donc je lis ces
livres et en fin de compte en lisant ce
livre je me rends compte que lévi
strauss a théorisé sur les croyances et
il a compris des choses exceptionnelles
sur des croyances en fait
pour des raisons politiques on connaît
il fuit la france durant la seconde
guerre mondiale et se retrouve bloqué
dans un village d'amérique du sud est
n'est en rien la faille de dit lui-même
il s'ennuie il se promène dans la forêt
amazonienne à la découverte de
différentes populations et il rencontre
deux tribus de même nature quasiment
deux thèmes population quelques semaines
d'écart même endroit et il se rend
compte que ces deux cultures
ces deux pendant ces 2 ces deux tribus
ont généré des cultures totalement
différentes pour un contexte qui est
quasi similaire
il est fasciné par ces différences et de
les comprendre alors comment ils les
voient ces différences parce qu'ils les
voient pas ce que ces tribus les maîtres
des signes qui sont différents raison
une manière vestimentaire de fond de
s'habiller différemment la différence
elles ont des habitats qui sont
différents ils ont une langue qui est
aussi différent d'une cuisine qui est
différente avec des cils comprendre
pourquoi c'est pourquoi autant de
différence pour des gens qui pourraient
être aussi ça aussi sibyllin peu comme
sparte et athènes en quelques sortes et
creusant il se rend compte que elles
n'ont pas les mêmes règles de vie elles
n'ont pas les mêmes interdits et ses
règles
ce sont des rituels une codification qui
ordonne et organise attributs et il se
rend compte que ses règles en fin de
compte sont rattachés à quelque chose de
supérieur à une croyance et il va
comprendre vraiment ce qui définit la
différence et de culture c'est qu'elle
n'en croient pas dans les mêmes choses
ces deux tribus l'une au milieu de la
forêt croix dans les oiseaux et le ciel
l'autre dans la rivière et les poissons
et donc en fin de course de manière
totémique et de manière biologique
ils ont accroché leur système de valeurs
à des croyances différentes qui se
raccroche à des mythes différents alors
oui ça c'est super intéressant parce que
si on peut se dire que moi je crois à
apple et donc je m'accroche quelque
chose chez apple c'est que cette
croyance elle peut être organisée
structurée de manière raisonnée donc de
manière logique donc je creuse un peu
plus loin et je commence à développer
des théories analytique me servant de
sémiologie d'anthropologie pour analyser
les marques en me disant que je vais
comprendre le fondement des croyances
des marques et puis un jour chier j'ai
une mission chez un de grandes
entreprises je pourrais dire est qu'elle
pour qui est dans la compétition et dans
le sport est donc je leur présente
différentes bibliothèques pour éviter en
disant voilà si vous voulez être une
marque de sport et malgré sportivité il
ya différents types de mythologie dans
la sportivité et au moment où je
commence ma présentation j'entends au
premier rang pas suffisamment fort que
tout le monde l'ait pas entendu mais
c'est insuffisant pour moi je veux
entendre qu'un guide qu'est ce qu'il
raconte
alors si vous êtes un truc de
l'ascenseur quand il se passe quelque
afin vent et personne ne se retourner et
donc je vous dis est ce que je fais les
du 6e j'ai entendu gens que je fais hop
une pirouette et jure pas et puis comme
je suis pas de cette nationale donc je
fini par dire j'ai entendu un
commentaire que quelqu'un quelque chose
là à dire personne dans les groupes a et
donc je dis bon apparemment il ya un
avis contraire à ce niveau théorique je
développe alors on va prendre un exemple
et vous vous devez vous rendre compte
que si vous pensez pas que sa marge
brute entre marc ça peut marcher pour
votre marque sauf que je n'ai pas dansé
exemple en fin de compte ce que je suis
au début de mes théories et est donc
j'ai pas des dizaines de clients qui
j'ai fait des spectres anthropologique
est bon et donc en fin de compte je
réfléchis je fais une marque et puis
bien il faut croire que tous deux
connaissent et puis je pense à apple rim
et apple
alors question la seule pourriez vous me
dire qu'elle et lui 300 apple mais je
leur dis ça avec le sentiment de se voir
mais je sais pas du tout
et donc je vous dis akamai qui fait de
trouver calme avant moi 170
l'intelligence collective cette somme à
mes dépends ailleurs donc pas
strictement rien donc j'attends que
quelqu'un veut sauver la bise et donc
personne je fais je prends un pas de
recul gimont très bien qu'elle soit un
peu difficile je vais simplifier la
question et je leur dis alors redéfinir
nos rides c'est facile en rituel le ritz
est en quelque sorte le mode relationnel
que l'entreprise veut établir avec le
reste du monde avec ses concurrents avec
ses clients
hélas au fond de la salle et ça je dois
dire que j'ai vécu longtemps au fond de
la classe donc que c'est qu'au fond de
la classe qui est toujours les meilleurs
et donc au fond de la salle il ya un
gars qui donnent la main il est oui j'ai
une idée je le dis m'a écouté je vous
écoute et de gamme reçoivent la peau
parce que moi même j'avais toujours pas
trouvé d'ailleurs un tournant et il vit
la désobéissance et là je reprends la
bobologie
effectivement la désobéissance et donc
qu'en face à tours le sort aujourd'hui
et donc est donc en fait effectivement
les options mais jolie ville à 18 ans à
qui carla les gens rumeurs dans la salle
et puis quelqu'un me dit microsoft
oui effectivement micro aider
on dira c'était pas et ce n'est pas le
dernier c'était il ya déjà 15 ans et
donc microsoft dit oui effectivement
microsoft mais et qui s'était qui avant
ibm microsoft
aujourd'hui google gmail c'est qui ça
arrive et est microsoft google parce
qu'on s'en fiche de la santé en
entreprise
aujourd'hui en fin de compte c'est la
représentant de l'autorité du marché en
fin de compte apple le désobéit qu'est
une seule personne celle qui fait la loi
et qui c'est qui fait la loi dans la vie
pas de prosélytisme
c'est dieu c'est en fin de compte le
mythe fondateur d'apple c'est peut être
que je suis se rattache au péché
originel
l'idée qu'en fin de seconde la marque
n'existe que parce qu'elle combat
l'autorité centrale du monde comme dans
les enfants en vue de l'organisation du
système est d'ailleurs quand apple est
suffisamment fort pour gérer générer une
nouvelle loi il désobéit à sa propre loi
sans que personne ne parle incohérences
tout monté des brocs du gris les fonds
en couleurs enfin deux minutes tu meurs
les gens mais il faut des produits gré
l'éléphant couleur quand les gens et
font en couleur il les fonds blancs
quand les gens les fondements et les
formes et heures et en fin de compte
personne ne se dit que cette marque est
chaotique
elle suit sa croyance alors un peu plus
loin je me dis bien c'est génial
maintenant j'ai eu quand même réussi à
démarrer pour ça je reviens à ma place
après avoir parlé à la seule et jouait
son ordinateur la pomme croquée
je ne sais d'ailleurs là la salle en
délire un bouddhisme enfin ils se sont
dit mais bon ce n'est quand même pas mal
et donc je sauve bat paul sauvé
présentation et je finis mon histoire
quelques mois après j'étais chez un
client lui dans le conseil personnel
c'était monsieur walsh ohlins or pour
ceux qui le connaissent pas volfoni
c'est un des grands pères du design
corporate il est plus de ce monde
aujourd'hui c'est un vieux monsieur déjà
à l'époque mais c'est un de ceux qui a
structuré mon métier qui a été pour voir
un point de référence est donc à la fin
de la réunion je vais voir monsieur
l'insee jeudi monsieur ohlins
vous êtes je crois contributeur du logo
d'apple bivouac voix parmi nous parler
donc dieu oui tout à fait l'orgie mais
alors qu'est ce qui vous a amené à faire
ce logo alors un peu comme une sorte de
disciples de vent 1 m et donc ils vivent
il y avait un logo c'était la pomme de
newton
legault comme ça et puis il ya eu un pic
tollé dicod le bac des macintosh et donc
voilà l'icône la pop
prof leveaux je pense qu'il n'avait pas
envie de vous parler
je pense que
il faut aussi été assez exigeant
designer français vient de donner des
conseils à une marque anglaise est donc
en vue là je suis un peu interloqué gym
à 100 et je me suis foulé la pomme
croquée n'en parle même pas alors je lui
mets monsieur ohlins époux sort dans le
zou je le fais en anglais donc monsieur
lice mais la pomme a les pitas pour les
croquer la pomme
et là il me regarde avec un air très
renfrognée minimes et so what
j'aimais beaucoup l'avaient fait croquer
la pomme ce que je mets des emplois et
la une libye
morgane barils par il paraît en lock out
est déjà parti je me retrouve tout seul
dans une salle de réunion que moi /
photo que j'étais catastrophé shmuli ça
fait des mois que je m'en a des dizaines
de gens en leur racontant qu'en fin de
seconde le mythe fondateur d'apple
c'est le péché originel est en fait le
temps que ça me monte au cerveau parce
que j'étais quand même sous le choc je
me rends compte qu'ils viennent faire la
deuxième dimension importante c'est
qu'en fin de compte la croyance est une
chose mais le pouvoir d'un croyance
c'est qu'en fin de compte c'est pas
conscient ça va au-delà la conscience
ils viennent de démontrer que lui même a
été manipulé par la propre force de la
marque
le fait que cette marque génère une
croyance tellement forte qu'elle
transcende même sa conscience et c'est
même des clients de la marque comme ça a
été le cas pour moi puisque a vraiment
bien fait un cauchemar pour que je me
rêve mais d'une nuit pour comprendre
pourquoi j'aimais tellement la marque
apple sait qu'en fin de seconde attachés
à la marque une sorte de lien fort et
indélébile parce qu'enfin donc j'ai dit
il ya cette croyance est en fin de
compte ce qui est intéressant c'est de
se dire qu'en définitive c'est que cette
croyance on peut dire mais se voit une
fois qu'on est que marco une croyance
bon bah en 57 croyances elle a un
pouvoir
elle crée du lien social alors on peut
toujours se dire que c'est toujours au
bénéfice des profits d'entreprises que
le lien social va s'établir entre les
gens qui travaillent dans l'entreprise
et ce qu'ils en deviennent clients mais
ça va au delà de ça parce qu'en fin de
compte ce lien social et cette
conscience que la marque génère liés à
cette pouvoir inconsciente et croyances
créer une conscience qui devient
collective et c'est là que ça devient
intéressant c'est qu'une conscience
collective n'appartient même plus à
celui qu'il a généré en l'occurrence la
marque elle peut la guider tels que la
nourrit elle a le devoir de l'amour
mais on ne peut pas la contrôler parce
que cette conscience deviennent
communautaire et l'honneur de l'internet
est encore plus fort ce qui s'est passé
gap change de logo
ils font ils avaient un carré bleu avec
une typo blanche très très belle il faut
un carré bleu qui grossit benoît sur
internet ils font n'importe quoi
la conscience collective de tous les
clients des internautes agrégé même de
ceux qui ne sont pas acteurs de marques
célèbres alors dix ans c'est n'importe
quoi
et eux d'oser dire aux internautes on
met à écouter dites douces qu'ouvrier
qu'en face et des internautes très
judicieusement de redire embauche une
agence de design c'est véridique jeu
suivant l'exemple parce qu'il est quand
même assez démonstratifs et est donc en
fin de compte de se rendre compte que
cette conscience collective
elle a ce pouvoir là de créer du lien
social mais d'avoir aussi des vertus des
rois des vertus éthique et président en
fin de compte au fond moi le cauchemar
que j'avais fait c'est qu'un jour
j'allais le conscient mais j'avais le
sentiment que la disparition d'apple
c'était sa disparition de cette de cette
pouvoir cette conscience collective qui
pour moi était enfin quand une seule
chose c'est qu'apple grâce en cinq ans
collective était d'une marque de prouver
merci